er ist mir ja eine schöne vorlage jetzt
auch gerade geliefert worden über die
frage sind fehler gemacht worden oder
nicht darum geht es gerade wir haben
jetzt über zwei jahre corona maßnahmen
hinter uns es geht um die frage gehen
wir in den herbst und viele viele fragen
sind noch offen nämlich erstens über
welche zahlen reden wir warum versperrt
man sich auch für landes aber einsetzen
und auf der bundesebene vor einer
evaluation über louis rung der zahlen
mit was gehen wir jetzt in den herbst
und natürlich nicht zuletzt die frage
bleibt auch dabei politik der spaltung
ist immer noch genannt
impfkampagne wird wieder hochgefahren
wird auch über die frage risiken und
nebenwirkungen der impfung und so weiter
gesprochen das ist das thema was mir als
anwalt natürlich am herzen liegt weil
ich auch schlichtweg sage das muss
dringend juristisch aufgearbeitet werden
weil es vielleicht auch einen beitrag
verein kann zur allgemeinen befriedung
wie stellen sie sich die juristische
aufarbeitung vor die stelle ich mir gar
nicht vor die ist schon ganz praktisch
weil wir haben tatsächlich ja während
der gesamten zeit sehr viele klagen
geführt wir haben an vielen
verwaltungsgerichten klagen geführt und
wir sind jetzt in der phase dass diese
ganzen einstweiligen verfahren laufen
jetzt eine hauptsache und da wird dann
schon mal ein bisschen ganz genauer
nachgeschaut das heißt also natürlich
standen auch die gerichte vor dem
problem dass sie im einstweiligen
verfahren mal gucken mussten und dann
wollen sie natürlich auch beeindruckt
davon die zahlen und kein einzelner
richter wir verantwortlich sein dass nun
alle wie die fliegen sterben und so
weiter sondern da jetzt kann man aber
ein bisschen auch ich sage mal die luft
die pause die vielleicht auch besteht
nutzen um dann das ganze juristisch
aufzuarbeiten und wer dabei auch klipp
und klar sagen ich rede auch nicht der
frage der rechtsstaat ist tot oder was
auch immer das wort sondern ich sehe aus
meinem umfeld letzten endes auch
positive beispiele wie man auch wieder
aufeinander zugeht ich sehe aber vor
allen dingen auch dass diese debatte die
auch sehr emotional geführt wird am ende
des tages vor den einrichtungen landen
muss bevor den institutionen dann nur
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat der
politik ja recht gegeben ja aber
bundesverfassungsgericht und politik
sind zwei schöne stichworte mehr muss
man dazu nicht sagen also ich bin da
sehr kritisch weil
viele erzählen ja auch immer unser jahr
das bundesverbraucheramt den
europäischen gerichtshof
beim europäischen gerichtshof da gibt es
gar erstaunliche entscheidungen da ging
es ja auch um die frage der der
bedingten zulassung der impfung auf
eu-ebene das war auch so ein punkt wo
eben auch der europäische gerichtshof
ganz klar auch gesagt hat welche
rechtswirkungen das hat und warum es so
wichtig ist auch auf nationaler ebene
darüber zu sprechen und warum es so
wichtig ist dass eben die einrichtung
mit reputation paul-ehrlich-institut und
so weiter ihre aufgabe ernst nehmen und
ich sage an der stelle das hat mich
schon am anfang der korona krise so
gestört dass man eine technisch
wissenschaftliche frage aber das ist ja
bei vielen anderen themen auch so
politisch überbaut und dann sozusagen
der gehört in die ecke der gehört in die
ecke das muss sozusagen wieder an sie
ein ganz praktisches beispiel für diese
überbau ja generell die ganze zu sagen
also keiner wagt sich an maßnahmen
überhaupt kritisch herum zu arbeiten und
zwar in gewissem schwob labor sagt ja
das stimmt nicht als würde ich sagen
natürlich da hat es auch entwickler
hatten
bestritten hier alles gut ich bin
verweisen dagegen also alle über einen
kamm zu scheren aber diese allgemeine
frage wie debattiert wird zu solchen
grundthemen das ist ja bei corona und
anderen themen genau dasselbe geht nicht
im zweifel nichts an weil ich einfach
sage ich als anwalt bin dazu
ausgebildeten sachverhalt zu ermitteln
und gerade bei corona kann ich keinen
sachverhalten in dem sinne ermitteln
weil mir die stellen die den sachverhalt
ermitteln könnten nämlich die
institution wie das robert-koch-institut
und andere den sachverhalt nicht
erklären und das führt übrigens auch
dazu dass auch viele leute sich einen
eigenen sachverhalt schaffen und dann
sagt man aber du bist du reagieren
erklärt doch den leuten mal und und
nicht und dieses zahlen gewöhnt was dann
sozusagen darüber hängt das ist
natürlich nicht verständlich wenn man es
auch nicht draußen sieht sozusagen und
deswegen muss es dahin wo es geklärt
werden kann das wird nicht auf straßen
geklärt das wird nicht in die debatten
den talkshows geklärt sondern am ende
des tages müssen wir den rechtsstaat
stärken dass er sowas auch auf und
nachbereitet und wir sagen können
passiert uns das noch mal laufen wir
wieder wind links in solche krise hinein
wie sehen sie das denn heparin als
unternehmer wenn sie zurückblicken auf
die korona pandemie ja mich mich
interessiert ja immer der mensch
dahinter tatsächlich als selbständiger
das brauche ich ihn der runde kamen zu
zellen war es sehr sehr schwierig ich
denke die orientierungslosigkeit war er
maßgebend für die ganze situation
ich denke aber auch die
informationsfülle die nicht aufbereitet
wurde passt ganz gut dazu
aufklärung wäre viel besser gewesen
finde ich weiß es war die erste pandemie
und es war für jeden neu aber mich hat
dieser wissenschaftliche ansatz der hat
mir gefehlt den wir in der universität
gelernt haben auch sie mit dem
doktortitel das ist ja ich habe ihre
cannabis rede im bundestag
gehört und die argumentativ nicht so gut
dass nur als nebenher
gerade ansprechen aber das können wir
besser cannabis sehr emotionalisiert
denn er weiß ich nicht weil er bloß in
einer anderen sendung ist als band erst
dann die frage der platz ja mehr ein
vertreter aus der politik im drinsitzen
bundestagsabgeordnete wenn sie die
vorgeführt auch ein von herr templin und
auch was die russische ausarbeitung
betrifft sind denn
bundesverfassungsgericht und bundestag
zwei stichworte die hand in hand gehen
also wir haben ja hier eine
gewaltenteilung in deutschland und wir
müssen als bundestag oder durch viele
politiker müssen immer wieder mal auch
leidvoll erfahren dass es diese
gewaltenteilung gibt und dass das
bundesverfassungsgericht
entscheidung der politik korrigiert das
ist häufig sehr schmerzhaft aber ich
sage auch klar das ist auch gut so weil
diese gewaltenteilung unseren
rechtsstaat ausmacht und auch eine
demokratie am ende stärkt deswegen
verwehre ich mich auch dagegen dass
irgendwie der eindruck entsteht
oder hier die sendung gegeben wird naja
das ist irgendwie nicht alles so sauber
und man muss das
bundesverfassungsgericht allgemein
anzweifeln also häufig geändert gesagt
dass das bundesverfassungs endes
bundesverfassungsgerichtes aber das bild
nur dazu sagen da geht es hand in hand
wenn die frage ist wenn die akteure das
tatsächlich miteinander vermischen es
geht ja schon jetzt wer miteinander
vermische einerseits mit der frage wo
sieht sich das war es ist ja es ist klar
das bundesverfassungsgericht ist ja
formal ein zwitterwesen es schwankt
immer zwischen gericht und
verfassungsorgan so immerhin ist ja auch
der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wenn alle
anderen ausfall am ende unser
staatsoberhaupt an letzter konsequenz da
kommt verfassungsorgan und oberstes
gericht zusammen und dann natürlich auch
die frage wie man parteien umgeht wenn
wir verfassungsklagen führen und ich
erfahre dann quasi oder meine mandanten
aus der presse dass eine entscheidung
gefallen ist da sieht sich offenbar das
bundesverfassungsgericht in einer
anderen rolle aber es ist keine kritik
am bundesverfassungsgericht selbst und
das ist eine wunderbare innovation diene
die man ernst nehmen muss aber ich habe
zunehmend anhand der entscheidung die
daherkommen den eindruck dass diejenigen
die die verantwortung weil ich
entscheidung zum beispiel wenn ich
alleine sehe wie bei der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht also da setzt sich
dann der senat hin und erklärt also
liebe leute das ist ja gar keine
impfpflicht natürlich formal ist es
keine nachweispflicht aber die die
betroffen sind können sich ja eine weile
raus ziehen dann ist irgendwann vorbei
mit was für einer arroganz geht man über
die hinweg die das
bundesverfassungsgericht schützen soll
weil es ist nun mal der hüter der
verfassung ist also ein hüter der
minderheit gesagt da ist die politik das
ist mehrheitsentscheidung aber ich
brauche jemanden der es korrigiert und
drauf guckt ob die mehr als entscheidung
richtig ist und das aber das recht keine
entscheidung der politik nicht weil wir
die gewaltenteilung haben also das
bundesverfassungsgericht trifft
eigenständig entscheidungen oder fällt
urteile wie gesagt häufig sind die auch
nicht im sinne der politik oder wir
müssen irgendwelche gesetze korrigieren
weil das bundesverfassungsgericht sagt
so geht das nicht und das zeichnet
unseren rechtsstaat aus wir halten uns
deswegen auch mit kritik zurück weil man
sagt man muss das auch respektieren man
ist nicht immer auch froh darüber
manchmal sagt man daher hat man sich
vielleicht etwas anderes gewünscht aber
ich glaube so eine allgemeine stellte
jetzt über das bundesverfassungsgericht
hilft und sich weiterhin punktgenau an
der unterseite
das ist ja allgemein gestellt und auch
oder indischen in den feldern sondern
ich glaube ich bin sicher dass diese
sehen es als kritiker ich sehe es als
jurist und da ist einfach der punkt wenn
wenn ich sozusagen den denjenigen die
wie juristisch ausbilden in den letzten
zwei jahren verfassungsrecht erkläre und
sie einfach erkennen dass sie das was
sie in einer klausur um ordentlich zu
lösen bei denen die die verfassung
bieten sollen nicht wiederfinden dann
ist das für mich eine juristische kritik
die ist legitim und das ist keine dass
sich die dass sie die gewaltenteilung
ernsten das erste das soll auch so sein
aber es ist faktisch so dass sich
zurzeit sagen muss die die die politik
die entscheidungen in der stelle das
stimmt so viel politik mit dass ich
sagen muss verspielt einsehen ja und das
ist genauso nicht wenig sagt er das wird
eher indirekt so mich sehr vor aber ich
will eigentlich gewiss ist nicht es ist
nicht genau natürlich hat ein
geschmäckle wenn herbert natürlich im
wahlkampf damals noch mit der
bundeskanzlerin auftritt dann kommt
diese entscheidung mit der frage ob die
bundeskanzlerin vom anderen seite der
erde sagen kann die wahl muss rückgängig
gemacht werden und dann kommt das bonus
fahren da ist das bundesland wie jetzt
gerade das beispiel das ja diese aussage
von merkel sogar korrigiert habe ich
hatte ja nicht im sinne der politik was
ist denn das aber ich will endlich
wieder einmal an die das machen wir da
ist denn das für eine geschwindigkeit in
das bundesverfassung der passiert etwas
was einer demokratie nicht ansteht und
monate später kommt die verfassungshüter
rinn um die ecke das darfst du nicht
dass wir ungefähr ich bin immer ich will
einfach nur an der vielleicht auch zum
alter zimmer in der der zuschauer ganz
ganz interessant ist weil die frage ist
ja also für die politik oder für unsere
gesellschaft was können wir aus den
vergangenen jahren lernen und was muss
man anders machen und in der tat sind
einige entscheidungen getroffen worden
auch in der politik die falsch waren und
die damals auch schon lächerlich waren
ich denke mal so an hamburger beispiele
da musste man draußen beim joggen maske
tragen beim joggen oder radfahren oder
spaziergehen draußen am samstag gab es
damals genau und da gab es damals schon
virologen die gesagt haben also draußen
ist die ansteckungsgefahr sehr sehr
gering man muss vor allem im innenraum
aufpassen und da würde ich für die
zukunft schlussfolgern dass man sagt die
verhältnismäßigkeit muss gewahrt werden
und die maßnahme sind zielgenau sein das
ist das was zum beispiel die politik
lernen muss und dass damals der peter
tschentscher in der rot grüne senat auf
das noch verteidigt haben und immer noch
auch kein schuldeingeständnis irgendwo
mal öffentlich dargelegt habe neu
gesetzten na ja da haben wir auch fehler
gemacht das glaube ich kostet in der tat
vertrauen und das muss die denkt schon
wieder massen genau und und was man und
was ihm das ist der zweite auch wichtige
punkt wir dürfen nicht zu einem
daueralarm modus kommen oder lauterbach
der ja weniger im moment
gesundheitsminister ist sondern eher so
eine art katastrophenminister oder angst
minister und wenn wir permanent den
ausnahmezustand ausrufen auch in zeiten
in denen wir zum beispiel die
intensivstation glücklicherweise
überhaupt nicht überlastet sind dann
stumpft irgendwann natürlich die
bevölkerung auch ab weil man seit naja
jeden tag kommt irgend eine
horrormeldung nimmt man das nicht so
ernst und gleichzeitig ist das eben
überhaupt nicht zielgenau leben wollen
sie dann muss die verhältnisse mehr ist
aber dass man dafür habe ich mich auch
immer das ist eine schöne anlage nehmen
sie die mit in den bundestag der
bundestag muss seine parlamentarische
rolle an der stelle ernst nehmen das hab
ich auch vermisst war alle in einer
starre waren hat sich das über
rechtsverordnung rausgenommen und vor
allem weil sie sagen zielgerichtet das
ist der punkt warum wir schlichtweg auch
evaluieren müssen weil wir haben jetzt
zwei jahre lang mit der keule um uns
herum geschlagen es wurden masken
verordnet wurden unternehmen in der
breite s wurden branchen kaputt gemacht
ich kriege rückmeldungen aus der kultur
und event branche da wird einem angst
und bange da wird da sitzen wir im
kalten ohne musik und freude sozusagen
im herbst dass das nimmt muss um
unbedingt mitgenommen wäre da muss auch
dann wenn sie jetzt als opposition sagen
das muss gibt dann soll das auch
getragen werden das muss auch eine
forderung sein dass man auch sagt da
sind fehler gemacht werden und nicht den
gleichen fehler noch einmal zu
wiederholen und deswegen ist das ebenso
entscheidend dass eben vor dem herbst
klar zu machen und was ich uns als ganz
besonderen appell mitnehmen weil das
auch schon wieder mitnimmt neben
unternehmern eben ein das gebe ich hier
der politik mit was den kindern in den
letzten zwei jahren angetan wurden was
mit tests und diesem permanenten ihr
seid infektionsherde an den schulen wo
lehrer im grunde angst aus strahlend vor
den kindern an den schulen das darf sich
nicht wiederholen
im zweifel könnte ich fast sagen denkt
über alles nochmal nach locker wie auch
immer bei den kindern am aller das ist
die nächste generation die das tragen
soll und wenn sie das politisch
mitnehmen wenn sich damals die leute
breitbeinig da vorstellen weil da muss
man schlichtweg sein da habe genug leute
die also ich muss das weniger mit dem
wir immer die auffassung vertreten habe
man muss viel stärker auch die kinder
und jugendlichen da in den fokus nehmen
an die es teilweise zu wenig gedacht
trommeln sie die leute zusammen ich habe
meine auch dass wir im wams wieder dabei
sind dann müssen alle mal kante zeigen
und sich nicht angst habe ich bin da
nicht mehr ich habe immer klartext
gesprochen